- Les touristesususususususususe
la Riviera Maya font le plein,
comme si la pandémie
était chose du passé.
n'a jamais fermé ses frontièreùt
fortement diminué.
Et ce, malgalertes à la sécuris
aux bandes criminelles,
de plus en plus actives.
Rien à craindre pour les grandt
blindés de tous les côtés.
Les risque
du côté des stations comme
Playa del Carmen ou Tull
où on soupçonne que
la drogue circule et
sont victimes d'extorsion.
Fin octobre, une poursuite
terminée dans une pizzeria
de Tulntntntntnt deux touristes
et en blessant plusieurs autres.
En novembre, des bandits so
venus de la mer pour régler
leurs comptes sur la plage
sans faire de victimes
parmi les touristes.
Les hôteliers, surtout
STÉPHANE PALMIERI,
hôtelier,
- C'est des luttes de place,
donc... il y a quand mêmes,s,s,s
marché sur... la drogue.
Il y a beaucoup de gens qui
viennent ici... de plein de pays
un accès facile aux drogues.
c,c,c,c,c,c, forcément,
c'est un grand marché et,
si c'est un gr y y y y y y y y .
et les clans entre eux
se bagarrent pour tenir...
pour tenir les points
- Situation intolérable
pour le président mexicain.
"Ces faits douloureux
des étrangers perdent la vie
vevevevevevent pas se répéter."
Et pour ça, pour la première
fois, il envoie l'armée :
1500 gardes nationaux
ne peut pas se permettrede perdt
de son industrie touristique,
de son produit intérieur brut.
Il faut rassurer
"Les choses sont plus
tranquille.......
Les gens nous le disent."
Avant, c'était les policeelelÉt
qui étaient sensées assurer
la sécurité du tourisme, mais
on doutait de leur efficacité.
accompagnées de la gardealalala.
- Ça, le bon côté de ça,
c'est qus s s s s s s s s s s st
les différentes institutio
bien, du coup, ça permet d'avoir
beaucoup moins de corruption.-Àa
de Tullum est fermée
pour enquêe e e e e e e e e e ee
en permanence.
Même chose à l'hôtel de
Puerto Morelos, où a eu lieu
surveillé par le nouveau
bataillon touristique,
plutôt bien accueilli.
difficile, mais la base
militaire me
dit ce résident mexicain.
Beaucoup d'étrangers ignoresés.
C'est le cas de cet Américain
de Washington qui ne s'inquiète
pas. Ces Torontoises sont
"Il y a bien eu une fusillade
r r r r r r r r récemment, ce e
de choses arrive", dit-elle.
À Playa del Carmen,
aiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiain de démolir
ce pionnier du tourisme local,
janvier 2017, une fusilladeavai,
dont un Canadien.
L L L L L L L L L L'envoi de le
à la Riviera Maya hausse
prises par les différents
gouvernements mexi
depuis 20 ans pour lutter
contre le crime organisé.vivivir
que cette zone touristique
majeure connaisse le sort
d'Acapulco, où les touristes
s'aventurer depuis longtempsesee
bandes de narcotrafiquants.eaea,
Radio-Canada, Cancu